David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 9-107B. The interviwee is Mr. Abram Perl. ‘P’ like in ‘Peter’, ‘E’ like in ‘Edward’, ‘R’ like in ‘Rabbit’, ‘L’ like in ‘Love’. It is Spool 9-107B.
David Boder: September 2nd, 1946. Locality: Tradate, Italy. Between— located in a...between Milano and Como. A castle given over to displaced persons’ community of the self-government of the Kibbutzim, the so-called groups of young men, both...of men and women, married and single, which [who] are...[have the] intention by means, legal or illegal, to enter Palestine. The eh, interview...This is Spool 107, starting at the twenty-first minute. The interviewee is Mr. Abram Perl, twenty-seven years old, who has a number of aliases: Perl, Baruch, and he intends to call himself in Palestine Abram Shlomi, which is a translation of his former name, Friedman.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Herr Perl, wollen Sie mal rüberkommen hier? Näher, ganz nah. Ja. Und sprechen Sie hier oder hier, nicht wahr?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] אָדער היר אָדער היר...
David Boder: [In German] Ja, so nicht ganz... also, aber es soll dann und wann... das Licht soll dann aufgehen, das zeigt...
Baruch Friedman: Ja.
David Boder: . . . dass Sie richtig sprechen. Kommen Sie—  [Schnitt in der Aufnahme] Herr Perl, wollen Sie uns noch mal sagen, wie Ihr Namen ist, wie alt sind Sie, und von wo... und wo sind Sie gewesen, wenn der Krieg hat angefangen.
Baruch Friedman: Das war... das...[in Yiddish] איז געװעזן...
David Boder: Ihr Namen?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] מײַן נאָמען איז פֿרידמאַן, ברוך.
David Boder: יאָ, ברוך פֿרידמאַן, יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. דאָס איז... געבױרן אין דער סלאָװאַקײַ, אין קורימאַ.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. װערענד דעם קריג בין איך געװעזן, אין יאַרע [יאָר] 42 װען ס’האָבן אָנגעהױבן די סלאָװאַקישע טראַנספּאָרטע געגן די ייִדן...
David Boder: [In German] Aber warten Sie mal! Ven hat der Krieg mit Slowakei angefangen!
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] די סלאָװאַקײַ האָט איבערהױפּט נישט איבער[גע]לעבט קײן קריג.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: װײַל זי איז געװעזן אונטער דײַטשער אָקופּאַציע.
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: נאָר די סלאָװאַקישע רעגירונג איז געװעזן באַײַנפֿלוסט פֿונעם... דײַטש,
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: אַזױ, דאַס [אַז] אין יאַרע [יאָר] 42 האָבן אָנגעהױבן די גרױסע טראַנספּאָרטע מיט ייִדן – דאָס איז דאָך/נאָך געװעזן אָנפֿאַנג אַפּריל...
David Boder: יאָ?
Baruch Friedman: און ס’האָט אָנגעהױבן די טראַנספּאָרטירונג פֿון ייִדן צירקאַ 70.000. דאָס האָט געדױערט די גאַנצע, עה, גאַנצן זומער בײַלײַפֿיק, ביז סעפּטעמבער.
David Boder: [In German] Erzählt mir, wie hat man es zusammen [In Yiddish] געקליבן די ייִדן, װי האַט מאַן די טראַנספּאָרטע, עה... װאָס איז אײַער פֿאַמיליע געװעזן, און װאָס האָט אײַער פֿאַמיליע פּאַסירט?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] אַלזאָ, דאָס איז געװעזן אין... בײַלײַפֿיק... יולי, נאָך פֿאָר דעם, װי איך האָב געװוּסט, אַז די טראַנספּאָרטע װערן אָנהײבן צו גײן, האָב איך מיך געהאַט פֿאַרשטעקט מיט מײַנע ברידער אין װאַלע.
David Boder: װי אַלט זענט איר געװען?
Baruch Friedman: בין אַלט געװעזן דעמאָלט... דאָס הײסט, מיט, עה... מיט פֿיר, װען דאָס... דאָס איז געװען אין 42ער יאָר.
David Boder: יאָ. נו?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: װי אַלט זײַט איר געװען?
Baruch Friedman: דאָס [איז] מיט 4 יאָר [צוריק?] – דרײַ און צװאַנציק (23).
David Boder: איר זײַט געװען 23.
Baruch Friedman: 23.
David Boder: די ברידער זײַנען געװעזן עלטער [ענגליש׃] אָר [ייִדיש׃] ייִנגער?
Baruch Friedman: דער צװײטער איז געװעזן אַ ייִנגערער ברודער, מיט צװײ יאָר [ייִנגער].
David Boder: [In German] Und was war die Beschäftigung von Ihre/ire Eltern?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] אַ געשעפֿצמאַן אין לאַנדװירטשאַפֿט, אין... אַ קלײנעם דאָרף.
David Boder: אַ קלײנעם דאָרף?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: אַהאַ. נו, אַלזאָ...
David Boder: האָט איר זיך פֿאַרשטעקט מיט אײַער ברודער אין װאַלד און...
Baruch Friedman: פֿאַר די טראַנספּאָרטן... פֿאַר די טראַנספּאָרטן...
David Boder: פֿאַר װאָס האָט איר דאָס געטאָן און װי האָט איר זיך פֿאַרשטעקט.
Baruch Friedman: װײַל איך האָב געהאַט פֿאָרױס[גע]זען, אַז דער פּלאַן, פֿון היטלער פּלאַן איז געװעזן אַזױ שטאַרק, דאַס, עה... איך האָב געװוּסט עטװאַס, דאַס/עס װעט קומען שלעכטס אױף ייִדן. אַ איך האָב געװאָלט װײניקסטנס אַ טײל פֿון דער פֿאַמיליע זאָל זיך רעטן – װעגן דעם האָב איך געזאָגט, אױב צװאַר די עלטערן זײַנען נישט געװעזן זײער דאַפֿיר, אַז איך זאָל מיך פֿאַרשטעקן, װײַל זײ האָבן געװאָלט׃ װאָס מיט יעדן פּאַסירט, זאָל מיט מיר פּאַסירן. איך האָב אָבער געזאָגט׃ נײן, אַ טײל פֿון דער פֿאַמיליע מוז בלײַבן און דאַמיט, אַה... װײניקסטנס יעמאַנד זאָל בלײַבן. אַלזאָ בין איך געגאַנגען מיט דעם ברודער, מיך פֿאַרשטעקט אין װאַלד.
David Boder: דערצײלט מיר׃ פֿון אַ פֿילאָסאָפֿישן שטאַנדפּונקט...
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: – איך עה, רעד איצט ניט פֿון אַן אַנדערן –
David Boder: װאָס הײסט עס: אַ טײל פֿון דער פֿאַמיליע זאָל בלײַבן?
Baruch Friedman: עס זאָל בלײַבן, װי מע זאָגט, אַ זכר פֿון דער פֿאַמיליע.
David Boder: אַ װאָס?
Baruch Friedman: װאָס... װאָס הײסט...
David Boder: [In German] [unverständlich] Nu, erzähl!
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] יאָ, עס איז... אַז עס זאָל בלײַבן װײניקסטנס אײן, אײן... יעדע פֿאַמיליע װיל, אַז עס זאָל בלײַבן עפּעס אײן נאַכקאָמען נאָך דער פֿאַמיליע.
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: אױך פֿון דעם גרונט אױס האָב איך עס געװאָלט, אַז װײניקסטנס אַ יעמאַנד זאָל בלײַבן פֿון [אונדז?].
David Boder: הם. האָט איר נישט געדאַכט, אַז װען איר װעט בלײַבן מיט אײַערע עלטערן, איר קענט זײ רעטן?
Baruch Friedman: איך האָב זײ געבעטן, אַז זײ זאָלן קומען... זײ...
David Boder: אַה! איר האָט...
Baruch Friedman: און איך האָב זײ נישט אײן מאָל געבעטן, און... – מערערע מאָל געבעטן, זײ האָבן, דאָס האָט מען נישט געקענט באַגרײַפֿן, אַז מע פֿירט די אַלע מענטשן פּשוט אין, אין, אין... אין... קרעמאַטאָריומס. און זײ האָבן נישט געהאָט/געװאָלט דאָס װיסן! און איך האָב פֿאָרױס געהאַט געזען...
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: . . . אַז דאָס קען פּאַסירן.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Also zuerst hat ir gebetn ayere eltern: ale zoln geyn?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] אַלע זאָלן גײן.
David Boder: נון, האָבן די עלטערן נישט געװאָלט (?)...
Baruch Friedman: זײ האָבן נישט געװאָלט.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] So, den hot ir gesagt, das, eh...
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] האָב איך געזאָגט׃ װײניקסטנס אײנער זאָל קומען. האָב איך אַלײן... ערשטנס בין איך אַלײן געגאַנגען, דאַן האָב איך מיטגעשלעפּט דעם ברודער. [אַזױ װײַט?] געװאָלט, דאַס [אַז] דער ברודער איז אױך געקומען.
David Boder: װי אַלט איז ער געװעזן?
Baruch Friedman: ער איז געװעזן מיט צװײ יאָר ייִנגער.
David Boder: עה, אַלזאָ איז ער געװעזן 21 יאָר...
Baruch Friedman: אײן און צװאַנציק (21) יאָר/יאָ.
David Boder: אַלזאָ. װי גײט מען עס אַװעק אין װאַלד? דערצײלט דאָס/אונדז די אײנצלהײטן! איך װעל אײַך זאָגן, הער, עה...עה, עה...פּערל׃
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: . . . [In German] Über die gemeinen Sachen [In Yiddish] hot men geshribn genug bikher...
David Boder: Mir viln visn, vos hat aykh [In English] personally [In Yiddish] pasirt...
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: . . .  פֿון טאָג צו טאָג, װען מע קען געבן (?).
David Boder: נו! [... – אומקלאָר]
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: נו!
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. אַלזאָ דאָס איז געװעזן גענױ דען עה... דען פֿיר־... אַז עס האָט אַנפֿאַנג...
David Boder: Nisht keyn datn bra[u]kht ir nisht hubn!
Baruch Friedman: נישט קײן דאַטן.
David Boder: נו!
Baruch Friedman: אַמאָל פֿאַר, עה... אױף דער נאַכט האָב איך מיך געהאַט אַנטשלאָסן, מיטן ברודער׃ אינדז גײן מע [מיר גײען] אין װאַלד אַרײַן. פּשוט אין װאַלד אַרײַן. – טראַנספּאָרטע זענען געגאַנגען כּסדר, אַז אינדז האָמער [מיר האָבן] געהאַט אונדז אין דער הײם פֿאַרשטעקט אַ ביסל – אַז[...? – אומקלאָר] גײן מיר!
David Boder: [In German] Also was heißt [In Yiddish] “transportn zaynen gegangen”?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] טראַנספּאָרטן זענען געגאַנגען – מ[ען] האָט גענומען פֿון אַלע געגנט, האָט מען גענומען ייִדן, מאַסן ייִדן, (אַר?)אײַנװאַגאָנירט אין... אַכציק אין אַ װאַגאָן אַרײַן, און אַװעקגעשיקט זײ סאָפֿאָרט אױף פּױלן, אױף מײַדאַנעק, טרעבלינקאַ, [...? – אומקלאָר]...
David Boder: Un vos/Und was hot [men...? Umklor] dort pasirt?
Baruch Friedman: דאָרט, איז זעלבסטפֿאַרשטענדלעך, אין קרעמאַטאָריומס...
David Boder: אַלזאָ...
Baruch Friedman: אַלע.
David Boder: [In English] Eh, I want to state that since Spool about number 100 we have replaced the ‘absolutely’ non-directive interview by slightly directive [methods]. That is, we are suggesting that they are talking [should talk] about the high points of their, eh...experiences. This is, of course, not exactly the best method because it has shown that if one gives them perfectly free reign, the...certain experiences come out very freely. It’s kind of a mixture [of methods], and we are experimenting with it.
David Boder: [In German] Also, sagen Sie: Wie sind Sie [In Yiddish] avekgegangen in vald?
Baruch Friedman: האָמער [האָבן מיר] צוזאַמענגענומען דעם רוקזאַק, װעלעכן איך האָ[ב] געהאַט פֿאָרבערײַטעט – װאָס יעדער ייִד האָט געהאַט פֿאָרבערײַטעט – און אַהינגעגאַנגען אין װאַלד אַרײַן.
David Boder: Vu iz a vald? Wo, wo...
Baruch Friedman: ערשטנס זען[ען] מיר געװעזן אין אַזאָ’ן[אַזױנעם]... צעלעט [געצעלט]. האָבן מיר מיטגענומען זיך אַ [גע]צעלט.
David Boder: אַ צעלט. װער אי[ז] דאָס געװעזן?
Baruch Friedman: דער ברודער און איך.
David Boder: יאָ. נו?
Baruch Friedman: אַ צעלט, מע האָמער [האָבן מיר] זיך געמאַכט אַ צעלט אין װאַלד, און דאָרט אונטערן פֿרײַעם הימל געלעבט – מיטגענומען זיך צ[ו] עסן אױף אַ װאָך צײַט...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: . . .  עה, ברױט, מיט פֿאַרשידענע קאָנזערװירטע מילעך [מילך] און [אַ]זױ װײַטער, און דאָרט האָמער [האָבן מיר] געלעבט בײַלײַפֿיק אַזױ אַ װאָך. [שפּעטער...?]
David Boder: װער איז... זײַנען אַנדערע מענטשן געװעזן מיט אײַך?
Baruch Friedman: נײן, נאָר איך און דער ברודער.
David Boder: װי װײַט איז דער װאַלד געװעזן פֿון דער הײם?
Baruch Friedman: דאָס איז געװעזן צירקאַ פֿינף [5] קילאָמעטער.
David Boder: פֿינף קילאָמעטער. זײַט איר אַלײן/אַרײַן געגאַנגען בײַ נאַכט?
Baruch Friedman: בײַ נאַכט אין װאַלד אַרײַן, און דאָרט זענ[ען] מיר געװעזן צירקאַ אַ װאָך אַלײן, גאַנץ אײנזאַם, אָן פֿאַרבינדונג, אָן אַל[-ץ?].
David Boder: װוּ האָט איר געפֿונען צו טרינקען?
Baruch Friedman: עה, דאָס איז... עה, אין װאַלד איז דאָ... פֿאַרשידענע פּאָטיקלעך, װאַסערלעך [זײַנען דאָ]...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: אָט דאָס האָבן מיט געהאַט.
David Boder: נו.
Baruch Friedman: און אױך צו װאַשן. שפּעטער האָבן מיר אָנגעהױבן די פֿאַרבינדונג צו, עה, געפֿינען דאָרט מיט אַ באַקאַנטן גױ, װעלעכער... אימר, זען[ען] מיר געקומען אין אַ נעהערן קאָנטאַקט, מיט װעלעכן, און, עה... מע האָמער [מיר האָבן] אָנגעהױבן מיט אים צו קומען נעהער [נעענטער] אין פֿאַרבינדונג, גאַנץ נאָענט. היצט [איצט], אַזױ, דאַס, מע האָמער [מיר האָבן] געזען, אַז אַלײן אין װאַלד קען מען נישט עקזיסטירן... דער לאַנג... די זאַך קען זיך זײער לאַנג פֿאַרציִען... האָבן מיר גענומען, צי אַז... זײַנען מיר מיט אים אַ ביסל נעענטער זיך צוזאַמענגעקומען. ער האָט אונדז אױפֿגענומען, ער האָט אונדז געהאַט דאָרט, אַנפֿאַנג מיט שװעריקײַטן, אָבער מיר האָבן אים צוגעזאָגט, װעלן מיר אים געבן געלט און, עה, פֿאַרשידענע זאַכן, װעלעכע זענען אין דער הײם נאָך געװעזן...
David Boder: די מאַמע האָט צוגעזאָגט?
Baruch Friedman: נײן, אונדז האָמער [מיר האָבן] אים צוגעזאָגט.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: מיר האָבן אים צוגעזאָגט...
Baruch Friedman: . . .  און, עה אַזױ, מע האַמער [מיר האָבן] אַרײַנגעשיקט דאַן אַ טעטל פֿאַר, עה, דאָרט אַהין פֿאַר די עלטערן, אַז זײ זאָלן אים עפּעס געבן זאַכן פֿון צימער (?) אַרױס און דערמיט (?), ער זאָל אונדז דאָרט באַהאַלטן.
David Boder: הם.
Baruch Friedman: אױס דעם גרונט האָבן מיר די עלטערן אױך גערופֿן דאַ צו דעם גױ, אַז זײ זאָלן אױך אַהינקומען – װײַל איצט האָבן מיר שױן געהאַט דאָרט אַ שטיקל פּלאַץ, װוּ זײ זאָלן זיך באַהאַלטן –
Baruch Friedman: איצט זײ האָבן אָבער נישט געװאָלט קומען. זײ האָבן געזאָגט׃ װאָס מיט אַלע ייִדן װעט זײַן, זאָל מיט זײ אױך זײַן. און אַזױ האָט אונדז דער גאָי אָנגעהױבן צו פֿאַרש... עה, האָט אונדז פֿאַרשטעקט, און עס איז... איז, עה... גאַנץ אָנגענעם געװעזן נאָך... ביז, עה... אַ... אַ צײַט.
David Boder: װאָס האָט איר געטאָן דעם גאַנצן טאָג?
Baruch Friedman: דעם גאַנצן טאָג האָבן מיר פֿאַרברענט מיט עבֿריתּ. האָבן מיר געלערנט, האָבן מיר מיטגענומען זיך ביכער, און מיר האָבן געלערנט עבֿריתּ. טראָץ דעם, װאָס די נערװן זענען געװעזן זײער געשפּאַנט, האָבן מיר געװוּסט׃ הײַנט מוז מען לעבן װי אַ בהמה׃ מע נעמט זיך פֿאָר גאָר נישט צו דענקען, אַפֿילו די סיטואַציע איז געװעזן שװער, גאָר נישט ץצ דענקען, נאָר צו לעבן מיר װײַס[ן], מיר האָבן אַ אױפֿגאַבע׃ איבערצולעבן דאָ דעם קריג און... עה... דאַמיט װעט, װעט זײַן שלוס, איך מײן.
David Boder: נו?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Also, wenn man lernt Ivrit, denkt man doch! Man studiert doch, vos men hot gelernt...
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] יאָ, איך מײן, דע... װאָס האָבן מיר געלערנט? אַלזאָ געלערנט האָבן מיר עבֿריתּ, איך האָ[ב] געזאָגט, די... תּנ”ך אױך...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: נאָר די צײַט צו פֿאַרברענגען און נישט צו דענקען אױף דער געגנװאַטר.
David Boder: אַהאַ. זאָגט מיר׃ װיפֿל ייִדיש, װיפֿל היברו, עבֿריתּ האָט איר געלערנט, װען איר זײַט געװעזן אַ יונגער מענטש, זײַט איר געפֿור־... – װיפֿל האָט איר געקענט?
Baruch Friedman: איך האָב, האָב װײניק געקענט, איך האָב געקענט מער [אַזױ װי װאָס (?)] מע האָט געלערנט אין חדר, אָבער דאָרט האָב איך מיך צוגעלערנט ריכטיק, עה ספֿרדיתּ.
David Boder: [In German] Was heißt das?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] דאָס הײסט, עה, דעם ריכטיקן נײַ־עבֿריתּ, מײן איך. נישט ייִדיש, װי מע זאָגט...
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: . . .  “לשון־קודש”,
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: פּערל: ... נאָר ספֿרדיתּ.
David Boder: Was me [In German] spricht Yidish?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] נײן. [מע רעדט טאַקע... (? – אומקלאָר)]
David Boder: Nayn, nayn... [In English] Hebrew?
Baruch Friedman: Hebr... [unintelligible]...
David Boder: [In German] Man spricht, eh, mit dem...
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] [אומקלאָר]
David Boder: נו!
Baruch Friedman: דאָס האָבן מיר געלערנט... – װײַל אַ געװיסע אײַנלײַטונג [= אַרײַנפֿיר] האָבן מיר געהאַט צו דעם – יעצט [איצט] האָבן מיר נאָר פֿאָרטגעזעצט.
David Boder: זײַט איר עס געװעזן ציאָניסטן?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ, ציאָניסטן זען[ען] מיר אַלץ געװעזן.
David Boder: אַלע געװעזן... דער פֿאַ־, דער פֿאָטער אױך?
Baruch Friedman: דער פֿאָטער איז געװעזן אַן [אַלטער?] איך מײן, פֿון חסידישן שטאַנדפּונקט׃ ער איז נישט געװעזן פֿאַר, ער איז נישט געװעזן קעגן.
David Boder: [In English] He was a khosid, your father?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] אַ האַלב חסיד, נישט אין גאַנצן... [...? – אומקלאָר], אַ האַלב־חסיד.
David Boder: נו.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: װײַטער?
Baruch Friedman: אַלזאָ, עה... דאַן איז געקומען אַזױ װײַט די צײַט, אַז, עה... האָבן באַקומען אַ בריװ, אַז די עלטערן זענען אַװעק.
David Boder: אָה, מע האָט זײ אַװעק...
Baruch Friedman: מע האָט זײ אַװעקגענומען פֿון טראַנספּאָרט, און איצט האָבן מיר געהאַט נאָך אַ שװערערע אױפֿגאַבע, [אומקלאָר] זענען מיר געבליבן הילפֿסלאָז, װײַל אַזױ װײַט האָט מען אונדז געהאַט געשיקט פֿון דער הײם אױך דאָרט  צו דעם גױ און עה, ... נאָך דעם האָבן מיר שױן...
David Boder: און װער איז מיטגעגאַנגען מיט די עלטערן?
Baruch Friedman: דאָס גאַנצע שטעטל. [אומקלאָר]
David Boder: אָבער איר האָט נאָך געהאַט אַ אַנדערן ברודער?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. דאָרט האָב איך נאָך געהאַט, עה... נאָך צװײ שװעסטערן און נאָך צװײ ברידער.
David Boder: און איר װײסט איצט עפּעס פֿון אײַערע עלטערן??
Baruch Friedman: גאָר נישט! גאָר ניט, איך װײס אַזױ פֿיל, אַז זײ זענען אָנגעקומען אױף מײַדאַנעק, שפּעטער האָב איך נאָך געהאַט אַ, אַ... געװיסן קאָנטאַקט, נישט מיט זײ, נאָר דורך, עה, רבֿ פֿרידער... דער פֿאָרזיצנדער פֿון דער סלאָװאַקישער ראַבינאַט, און ער האָט מיך געהאַט פֿאַרשטענדיקט, אַז זײ זענען צוגרונדע געגאַנגען בײַלײַפֿיק אין, אין... סעפּטעמבער/אָקטאָבער צײַט, אין מײַדאַנעק.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Und Ihre brider?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] אױך, אַלעס! אַלעס, אױך...
David Boder: נו. אַלזאָ...
Baruch Friedman: נאָך דעם, אַזױ װײַט, דאָס איז שױן געװעזן, אַזױ בין איך אָנגעזעסן בײַ דעם גױ... ביז פֿעברואַר־צײַט דרײַ און פֿערציק. צוליב, עה... מאַטעריעלע און פֿינאַנציעלע באַדינגונגען האָב איך געמוזט פֿון דאָרטן אַװעק. איך האָב אים נישט נישט געקענט מער צאָלן, האָב איך מיך פֿרײַװיליק געהאַט געמאָלדן אין אַ סלאָװאַקישן אַרבעטסלאַגער, װעגן דעם, װײַל די סלאָװאַקישע אַרבעטסלאַגער זענען נישט מער טראַנספּאָרטירט געװעזן, זענען געבליבן... דאָס הײסט אין דרײַ און פֿערציקער יאָר האָט מען נישט מער טראַנספּאָרטירט ייִדן פֿון דער סלאָװאַקײַ.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: . . .  נאָר עס זענען געבליבן סלאָװאַקישע ייִדן אין סלאָװאַקישע אַרבעטסלאַגערס.
David Boder: זאָ, אין װעלכן יאָר האָט מען טראַנספּאָרטירט?
Baruch Friedman: אין צװײ און פֿערציקער יאָר.
David Boder: און װי ערקלערט איר עס, אַז מע האָט אױפֿגעהערט?
Baruch Friedman: מע האָט אױפֿגעהערט – ערשטנס זי נישט געװעזן מער ייִדן, ס’איז נאָר/נאָך געװעזן – זיבעציק טױזנט ייִדן זענען אַרױס, און די איבעריקע זענען געבליבן נאָר צוליב פּראָטעקציע, װאָס [זײ?] האָבן זיך געלאָזט אָפּצאָלן פֿאַר געלט, די סלאָװאַקישע רעגירונג.
David Boder: װיפֿל, שעצט איר, זײַנען געבליבן?
Baruch Friedman: ס’זענען געבליבן צירקאַ פֿופֿצן טױזנט ייִדן.
David Boder: איר מײנט עס צו זאָגן, דאַס... איר מײנט עס צוגן, די טשעכאָ־סלאָװאַקײַ האָט נישט געהאַט מער װי הונדערט טױזנט ייִדן?
Baruch Friedman: נײן, דאָס איז נאָר די סלאָװאַקישע רעגירונג. נאָר די סלאָװאַקײַ. װײַל די סלאָװאַ־, טשעכײַ איז דאָך געװעזן... איז דאָך געװעזן פּראָטעקטאָראַט.
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: דאָס איז נאָר געװעזן, נאָר... בלױז סלאָװאַקײַ, [אומקלאָר].
David Boder: אַהאַ. ניט סודעטען...
Baruch Friedman: נײן, נײן, נײן.
David Boder: אַהאַ, [אומקלאָר]. אַלזאָ?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. בין איך געקומען צוזאַמען מיטן ברודער און...
David Boder: [In English] One moment. This concludes Spool 107. We really should have started a new spool. We are going over now to the new one, and we will splice the ten minutes of Spool 107 to 108 eventually. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording taken at Tradate, bewteen Como and Milano in Italy on September 2nd, 1946. Abram [ends abruptly]...
David Boder: Italy, September the 2nd, 1946. Tradate, a community place for the Kibbutzim, displaced young persons, men and women, who strive by all means, legal or illegal, to achieve their goal, and that is to locate themselves in Palestine. The, eh...person reporting is Abram Perl, [age] twenty-seven, from Czechoslovakia, who eh...is here in one of the Kibbutzim.
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] איך בין דאַן שפּעטער אָנגעקומען...
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Alzo, Her Perl, zi haben mir gezogt, vi ze hobn zikh gemeldet tsu deym, eh, [In German] freiwilligen tschechischen Arbeitslager...
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] סלאָװאַקישן.
David Boder: . . .  slovakishn arbaytslager, [In English] because... man... [In Yiddish] fun (marts?) 43 hot men ufgehert tse shikn
Baruch Friedman: טראַנספּאָרטן...
David Boder: טראַנספּאָרטן, עה, דאָס הײסט צו פֿאַרשיקן מענטשן נאָך טרעבלינקאַ, נאָך מײַדאַנעק, פֿון, עה... סלאָװאַקײַ, עה, פֿון סלאָװאַקײַ. און איר האָט מיר געזאָגט, אַז אין גאַנצן זײַנען געבליבן [דײַטש׃] אונגעפֿער [ייִדיש] פֿופֿצן – צװאַנציק טױזנט ייִדן פֿון די הונדערט טױזנט אין דער סלאָװאַקײַ, און די זײַנען געװעזן מײַסטנס רײַכע לײַטע, װאָס האָבן געהאַט פּראָטעקציעס פֿון געלט, און אין אַנדערן זין זײַנען עס געװעזן, װער? מענטשן, װאָס האָבן זיך באַהאַלטן.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: [In German] Ja. Nu, gehen Sie weiter.
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] אַלזאָ איך בין אָנגעקומען אין דריטן פֿעברואַר, עה... פֿיר און פֿער־, דרײַ און פֿערציק בין איך אָנגעקומען נאָך לאַגער װיזשניע. דאָס איז אין דער סלאָװאַקײַ. מיט, צוזאַמען מיט דעם ברודער, װעלכן איך האָב, איך בין געװעזן פֿאַרשטעקט.
David Boder: און די פֿאַמיליע איז שױן געװעזן ... פֿאַרניכטעט
Baruch Friedman: די פֿאַמיליע איז שױן געװעזן, לאַנג שױן געװעזן  פֿאַרניכטעט, דעמלט.
David Boder: און דאָס איז געװעזן אַ... אײַער פֿאָטער, אײַער מוטער און...?
Baruch Friedman: און די געשװיסטער. אַלע געשװיסטער.
David Boder: Geschwister / Vifil? (?)
Baruch Friedman: זענען מיר געװעזן צירקאַ פֿופֿצן, װײַל דער ברודער, אײַן ברודער איז שױן געװען פֿאַרהײַראַט מיט קינדער, אַלזאָ צירקאַ גאַנצע פֿאַמיליע פֿון פֿופֿצן מענטשן זענען מיר צװײ געהאַט געבליבן.
David Boder: זײַט איר נאַכער צוריקגע־... האָט איר נאַכער פּראָבירט זײ צו זוכן?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. אַז איך האָב דערװענט, דורך הרבֿ פֿרידער, דער פֿאָרזיצנדער פֿון, עה, ... פֿון דער סלאָװאַקײַ, װאָס ער איז דעמאָלט געװעזן, און ער האָט פּראָבירט אַ סך, [אומקלאָר] סאָביבאָר, אָבער אַלע זענען שױן געװעזן [אומקלאָר], פֿאַסט [= כּמעט] אַלע.
David Boder: “פֿאַסט אַלע” – האָט איר עמעצן, װעמען געפֿונען?
Baruch Friedman: אײניקע [= עטלעכע] האָבן נאָך געזאָגט/געזוכט [אומקלאָר], אײניקע זענען שפּעטער דאַן געשטאָרבן.
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: ס’איז, ס’איז, ס’איז...
David Boder: [In German] Naja.
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] דאָס איז נישט אַזױ... אַזױ איצט בין איך... מיר זענען דאַן אָנגעקומען [אין?] אַנדער לאַגער, װיזשניע.
David Boder: װער איז דאָרט “מיר”?
Baruch Friedman: איך מיט דעם ברודער.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: זענען מיר דאָרט... גאַנץ גוט געלעבט... אָנפֿאַנג... מע האָט אַ ביסל געאַרבעט... און, עה, און די סלאָװאַקישע ייִדן, װעלכע זענען געװען אין דרױסן, האָבן אונדז אונטער[גע]שטיצט. אַזױ, ס’האָט זיך גאַנץ גוט געלעבט.
David Boder: דאָס איז געװעזן אַ... ייִדישער לאַגער?
Baruch Friedman: אַ רײן ייִדישער לאַגער, אָבער מיט גױיִשע לײַטונג, [ס’הײסט?] מיט סלאָװאַקישע לײַטער.
David Boder: יאָ. װיפֿל מענטשן זײַנען... ייִדן זײַנען געװען דאָרטן?
Baruch Friedman: צירקאַ דרײַ הונדערט.
David Boder: און װי האָט מען געלעבט דאָרטן?
Baruch Friedman: מע האָט, עה... מיר זענען געװען ייִנגלעך, האָבן געלעבט פֿינף ייִנגלעך אין אײן צימער.
David Boder: פֿון װאָס האָט מען גענומען די צימער, [דײַטש׃] װאַס װאַר דאַס?
Baruch Friedman: דאָס איז געװעזן אַמאָליקס האָטעל, אַ באָד – אַ באָד איז דאָס...
David Boder: [In English] Yes. [In German/Yiddish] A kurort.
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] אַ קוראָרט, װיזשניע, יאָ. און דאָרט האָט מען געמאַכט אַ לאַגער, און... מע האָט דאָך גאַנץ גוט געלעבט, סע געװעזן בעטן און... אָנשטענדיק – נאָך קאָצן׃ נישט אַזױ װי אַ לאַגער אין אױשװיץ.
David Boder: יאָ. נו?
Baruch Friedman: איז, איך װיל אַרױסברענגען׃ דאָרט, אַזױ װי ס’איז די געגנט עה... איז עה... פֿאַרבונדן מיט גרױסע בערג... דאָרט די גאַנצע געגנט איז געבירגיק מיר...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: האָט מען אָנגעהױבן צו זוכן פֿאַרבינדונג מיט פּאַרטיזאַנען, און מע האָט גערעדט מיט מעגלעכקײַטן פֿאַר עס װעלן נאָך קומען אַמאָל טראַנספּאָרטן, זאָל מען געזיכערט זײַן און נישט קומען אױף אױשװיץ אָדער טרעבלינקאַ.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Nu, zogt mir - erzählt mir e bisl iber... fun di partizanen: Zayt ir [oykh danakh arayngekumen?]
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] שפּעטער זענען מיר...
David Boder: [...? – umklor] kumen, [...? - umklor]
Baruch Friedman: אַם אָנפֿאַנג האָבן מיר געמאַכט אַלײַן זיך פּלאַנען [= פּלענער] זענען מיר אַרײַן געגאַנגען אין די װעלדער אַרײַן, געמאַכט זיך בונקערס, אונטער־ערדישע, מיט... פֿאַרשאַפֿט זיך געװער...
David Boder: איר האָט נאָך געקענט גײן צו דו װעלדער, מע האָט אײַך אַרױס געלאָזט פֿון לאַגער?
Baruch Friedman: מיר זענען געגאַנגען... ס’איז נישט װײַט געװעזן פֿון װאַלד, און מיר האָבן זיך אַרױסגעכאַפּט, אַמאָל אַ זונטיק, אַז מע האָט נישט געאַרבעט... און מיר האָבן פּרוּביטרט, פֿאַרשידענע מעגלעכקײַטן אָנגעװענדעט, אַז מיר זאָלן דאָך דאָס לעבן רעטן, רעטן פֿאַר עס װעט קומען נאָך אַמאָל צו אַ טראַנספּאָרטירונג.
David Boder: הם.
Baruch Friedman: איצט איז עס געװעזן...
David Boder: Und was hat man gearbetet?
Baruch Friedman: געאַרבעט האָט מען מײַסטנס פֿאַך־אַרבעט.
David Boder: און װאָס האָט איר געאַרבעט?
Baruch Friedman: איך בין פֿון באַרוף שריפֿטמאָלער און רעקלאַמע־מאָלער, האָב איך געאַרבעט בײַ מאָלערײַ, ס’איז געװען אַ ערצײַגונג פֿון שפּילצײַג.
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: שפּילצײַג־ערצײַגונג.
David Boder: יאָ?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. האָב איך דאָרט בײַ דעם געאַרבעט. ס’איז נישט שלעכט געװעזן. איך קען ניט זאָגן, אַז די גאַנצע צײַט איז שלעכט געװעזן.
David Boder: נו, װײַטער.
Baruch Friedman: נאָר, אָבער... דאָס איז װידער געװעזן אַ [אומקלאָר]...
David Boder: Das war doch bay di Slovakn?
Baruch Friedman: בײַ די סלאָװאַקן, יאָ.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: די דײַטשן האָבן איבערהױפּט נישט געהאַט קײן צוטריט דאָרט. זענען מיר געװעזן סלאָװאַקן, זענען מיר געװען באַײַנפֿלוסט פֿון דײַטש, אָבער... שלעכט זענען זײ נישט אַזױ געװעזן.
David Boder: נו...
Baruch Friedman: איצט זענען מיר... יאָ. אַלזאָ דאָס איז, אַזױ האָבן מיר געלעבט ביז... פֿינף און צװאַנציקסטן אױגוסט פֿיר און פֿערציק.
David Boder: הם.
Baruch Friedman: דעמלט איז... יאָ, ביז דאַהין האָבן מיר נאָך געהאַט פֿאַרבינדונג שױן מיט די פּאַרטיזאַנען... און מיר האָבן שױן געהאַט געװער, אײגנס, עה, פּיסטאָלעטן – אַזױ פֿאַר ס’װעט געװען געקומען צו עטװאַס אַ טראַנספּאָרטירונג, זענען מיר געװען אָרגאַניזירט, אַ װידערשטאַנד צו לײַסטן.
David Boder: אַהאַ. און די פּאַרטיזאַנען װאַרען ייִדן אָדער קריסטן?
Baruch Friedman: נײן, פּאַרטיזאַנען זענען מײַסטנס געװעזן נאָר רוסן.
David Boder: אָה, רוסישע פּאַרטיזאַנען?
Baruch Friedman: רוסישע פּאַרטיזאַנען, װעלכע זענען אַריבערגעקומען אין דער סלאָװאַקײַ אַרײַן.
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: און מיט זײ זענען מיר אין קאָנטאַקט [געקומען?] דורך אײנעם, װעלכער ער איז... געהאַט די הױפּט־פֿאַרבינדונג דורך בראַטיסלאַװאַ. און מיט דעם זענען מיר געװען אין פֿאַרבינדונג. אַלזאָ עס איז געקומען דער פֿינף און צװאַנציקסטער אױגוסט, עה... איז אינצװישן... דאָס איז, װען דער סלאָװאַקישער אױפֿשטאַנד איז געװען אָרגאַניזירט, אַה... איז געקומען אַ מחנה מיט פּאַרטיזאַנען, און זײ האָבן אונדז באַפֿרײַט, דעם גאַנצן לאַגער, דאָס הײסט אין צוזאַמענהאַנד מיטן אױפֿשטאַנד, ...
David Boder: אין פֿיר און פֿערציק?
Baruch Friedman: אין פֿיר און פֿערטציקער יאָר, אין אױגוסט, און זײ האָבן סאָפֿאָרט גענומען, עה, יעדער פֿרײַ – דאָס הײסט, יעדער אײנער איז פֿרײַ געגאַנגען, יעדער אײנער װי ער האָט געװאָלט, איז געגאַנגען – און אַ סך פֿון אונדזערע ייִנגלעך זענען פֿרײַװיליק אַרײַנגעטראָטן אין קאַמף קעגן דײַטש, װען/און/דען דער דײַטש האָט אױפֿגעשטעלט שװערע דיװיזיעס קעגן דעם, ער האָט געמאַכט... דעמאָלט האָט... איז געשען די בעזאַצונג פֿון דער סלאָװאַקײַ, דורכן דײַטש...
David Boder: יאָ?
Baruch Friedman: . . .  און... יאָ? און, עה... נאָך די... די ייִדן זענען אַזױ... די גאַנצע מחנה פֿון די ייִדן זענען אַזױ צוזאַמענגענומען, נישט נאָר פֿון אונדזער לאַגער, אױך פֿון לאַגער נאָװאַקי...
David Boder: הם.
Baruch Friedman: װעלכע הונדערטער ייִדן – פֿיר אָדער פֿינף הונדערט ייִדן האָבן זיך צוזאַמענגענומען, און מע איז געגאַנגען... קעגן דען... שטױס פֿון די דײַטשן, און אױך פֿון די סלאָװאַקן, װעלעכע זענען... זײ האָבן געהאַלטן מיט טיסאָ...
David Boder: די דײַטשן.
Baruch Friedman: . . .  טיסאָ און טוקאַ רעגירונג.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Ale. Ayn moment. Was hat pasirt dem 25. eh... August?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] אױגו[סט]... דעמלט איז געקומען דער, דער שטױס.
David Boder: אַלזאָ.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: װילט איר מיר באַשרײַבן פֿון פֿיר און צװאַנציקסטן אױגוסט ביז צום זעקס און צװאַנציקסטן, אַלעס, װאָס האָט זיך דאָרט אין אײנצלנען פּאַסירט! װען איר זיך נאָך דערמאָנט.
David Boder: נו?
Baruch Friedman: די ... צײַט/זײַט... [אומקלאָר], װען עס איז די [אומקלאָר].
David Boder: אַלע, אַלע, אַלעס.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: װאָס האָט איר געטאָן דעם מאָרגן, װאָס האָט [אומקלאָר] פּאַסירט.
Baruch Friedman: פּאַסירט. אַלזאָ. װעל איך אָנהײבן מיט אײן טאָג פֿריער. דעם דרײַ און צװאַנציקסטן אױגוסט בין איך געװעזן אין בראַטיסלאַװאַ. איך האָב געזאָלט ברענגען פֿאַרשידענע, עה... פּיסטאָלעטן און מוניציאָן פֿון בראַטיסלאַװאַ.
David Boder: זײַט איר געװעזן דאָרטן לעגאַל?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ, איך האָב באַקומען אַ ערלױבניס [דערלױבעניש] פֿון, עה... פֿון דעם אָנפֿירער פֿון לאַגער, אָבער אױף אַן אַנדערן גרונט – ער האָט נישט געװוּסט, אױף װעלעכן גרונט.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Ja. Was far a grunt hot ir im gegebn?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] איך האָב אים אָנגעגעבן אײַנצוקױפֿן... עפּעס... קאַפּלאַך אײַנצוקױפֿן, און אַזױ װײַטער – פֿון געשעפֿטלעכן גרונט. און אַזױ װײַט האָבן מיר באַקומען ערלױבניס [דערלױבעניש].
David Boder: הם.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. יאָ, װאָס איז געװעזן?
David Boder: אַװוּ זײַט איר געװעזן? אין בראַטיסלאַװאַ, דעם דרײַ און צװאַנציקסטן.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. אַהײמקומענדיק, אױף דער נאַכט, האָב איך אינצװישן געהערט, דאַס דער דײַטש באַזעצט די סלאָװאַקײַ. איצט האָב איך נישט געװוּסט, אַז איך האָב צוריק צו קומען אין לאַגער אַרײַן אָדער נישט צוריק צו קומען. װי אַז איך קום אַרײַן אין לאַגער אַרײַן, די דײַטשן זענען אױך אַרײַנגעקומען. איך בין געװעזן אין אַ פֿאַרצװײפֿלטער שטימונג. [איך] האָב נישט געװוּסט, װאָס איך האָב צו טאָן. געפֿרעגט האָב איך מיך׃ איך האָב דאָרט אַ ברודער איז איך מוז אַהינגײן צו אים און... װאָס װעט זײַן װײַטער, װײס איך נישט. און אין צוג נאָך האָב איך געהערט, אַז די סלאָװאַקן לײַסטן אַ װידערשטאַנד. און עה... קום איך ביז צום לאַגער אַרײַן/אַהײם, בײַ נאַכט דאָס איז געװעזן, אַזױ אום צװעלף, אַז דער גאַנצער לאַגער איז אױף – קײנער שלאָפֿט נישט – און עה... דאָס איז אַ רירנד[איק]ע שטימונג.
David Boder: [In German] Eine Aufregung?
Baruch Friedman: Aufregung.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: און איצט... האָט מען געװאַרט, װאָס װעט זײַן. אײניקע האָבן געזאָגט, שױן, ס’איז שױן קאַפּוט, מע האָט שױן דאָס לעבן פֿאַרלױרן, אײניקע זענען... האָבן נאָך געהאַט אַ שטיקל האָפֿ[ע]נונג, װעגן דעם, װײַל מיר האָבן געהאַט געדענקט, אַז מיר זאָלן/װעלן לײַסטן אַ װידערשטאַנד און װעלן מיר זיך באַשליסן... אָנשליסן אַן די פּאַרטיזאַנער. דאָ איז אָט־דאָ געשען עפּעס אַנדערש. אַז דער אױשטאַנד, װעלעכרע איז געװעזן אָרגאַניזירט, אַז די גאַנצע סלאָװאַקײַ זאָל באַפֿרײַט װערן, איז טײל געלונגען, דאָס הײסט, אין דער... געגנט פֿון באַנסקאַ ביסטריצאַ. דאָרט איז געקומען אַלע פּאַרטיזאַנען, װעלעכע זענען געװען – מע האָט זײ פֿאָרהער אָרגאַניזירט, מיט רוסישע צוזאַמען – און עס האָבן אַנטװאָפֿנט דאָס מיליטער, די אומגעבונג, און... און [איבעראַל? (= אומעטום?)] געגאַנגען אײן בעזאַצונג נאָך דער צװײטער פֿון דער שטאָט דאָרט. עה... באַנסקאַ ביסטריצאַ האָבן זײ פֿאַרכאַפּט די... די ראַדיאָ־שטאַציאָן [= סטאַנציע], און מע האָט [דײַטש׃] געמעלדעט [געמאָלדן] דאַס [ייִדיש] װי אַ פֿרײַע טשעכאָסלאָװאַקײַ. דאָס איז געװעזן... בײַלײַפֿיק... עה... דעם פֿיר און צװאַנציקסטן... דעם פֿינף און צװאַנציקסטן װידער זײַנען געקומען פּאַרטיזאַנען פֿון די גאַנצע גרופּן דאָרט צו אונדזער לאַגער װיזשניע און זײ האָבן אונדז אױך באַפֿרײַט, און זאָפֿאָרט אַ טײל פֿון דער גאַנצער יוגנט גענומען צום פֿאָרשמאַרש, דאָס הײסט, צום באַזעצן, און אין פֿאָרשטױס, עה, װעלעכער דער... דער צװײטער טײל פֿון דער סלאָװאַקײַ – די, װעלעכע זײ האָבן געהאַלטן מיט די דײַטשן – קעגנזײַטיק קעמפֿן.
David Boder: נו. װײַטער.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. איצט איז געװעזן... דער, עה... דער אַה׃ מיר האָבן זיך, דער ברודער און איך, האָבן נאָך אָנפֿאַנג נישט אײַנגעטראָטן, מיר האָבן געדענקט׃ ס’איז נאָך צײַט, מע װײסט נאָך נישט, אפֿשר װעט קומען אַ שװערערער מאָמענט.
David Boder: װוּ זײַט איר געבליבן?
Baruch Friedman: מיר זענען דאַן אַװעק אױף זװאָלען, װױנען, אַהין, אין שטאָט אַרײַן.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: הונדערטער ייִנגלעך זענען געפֿאַלן קרבנות, [װעגן דעם װאָס זײ האָבן זיך געװאָרפֿן גלוט און פֿײַער אַרײַן] אין קאַמף קעגן די... קעגן די דײַטשן, און קעגן די הלינקאָװצעס, װעלכע זײ האָבן געקעמפֿט אױך...
David Boder: װאָס מײנט דאָס – גלינקאָװצעס?
Baruch Friedman: הלינקאָװצעס – דאָס איז געװעזן דער לינקער פּאַרטײ, װעלעכער ס’האָט געקעמפֿט קעגן די טשעכאָסלאָװאַקאַז.
David Boder: Linka?
Baruch Friedman: Hlinka. Andrej Hlinka.
David Boder: לינקאַ. װי עה, מע שרײַבט עס?
Baruch Friedman: H-L-I-N-K-A.
David Boder: דאָס... הלינקאַ איז געװעזן, זאָצוזאָגן [אַזױ צו זאָגן], אַ, עה... פֿאַראַטער?
Baruch Friedman: ער איז געװען דער פֿערעטער פֿון דער טשעכאָסלאָװאַקײַ.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. און שפּעטער זענען זײ געגאַנגען אין זײַן גײַסט, דאָס הײסט׃ אַ זעלבשטענדיקע סלאָװאַקישע רעגירונג.
David Boder: און די ייִנגלעך זײַנען געפֿאַלן, װײַל זײ זײַנען געװעזן אױף זײַן זײַט, אױף לינקער זײַט?
Baruch Friedman: נײן. זײ זענען געװען אױף אונדזער זײַט, און זײ האָבן געקעמפֿט קעגן זײ, זענען נישט געװעזן אױסגעאיבט [= געניט].
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: זײ האָבן דאַן/נאָר באַקומען בלױז אַ געװער אין דער האַנט אַרײַן, זײ האָבן גאָר ניט... מע האָט זײ נאָר קױם געװיזן זײ זאָלן/האָבן צו שיסן, זענען נישט געװעזן אױסגעאיבט, זענען זײ געפֿאַלן אַלע װי פֿליגן. זײער אַ גרױסער טײל.
David Boder: אַלזאָ איר דענקען, זײ זײַנען געפֿאַלן װי פֿליגן, װײַל זײ האָבן נישט געהאַט קײן פֿאָרבערײַטונג?
Baruch Friedman: קײן פֿאָרבערײַטונג... אַ ריכטיקע פֿאָרבערײַטונג. װײַל מיר זענען געװען אין לאַגער, האָט מען נישט געקענט אַזױ װײַט אױסאיבן, מעגלעכקײַטן. און די סלאָװאַקן אַלײן אַ טײל האָבן גרױסע פֿאַראַטונג געמאַכט, אױך אין דעם אױפֿשטאַנד. אין פּרעסבורג צום בײַשפּיל האָט געזאָלט זײַן דער בריק אױפֿגעשפּרענגט, און... װעגן דעם איז דער אױפֿשטאַנד נישט געקונגען. און אין פּרעשאָװ װידער, אין דער אָסט־סלאָװאַקײַ, איז אױך נישט  געלונגען דער אױפֿשטאַנד, אױך דורך אַ פֿאַראַט פֿון די סלאָװאַקן. אַזױ דאַס דער... דער צענטרום [צענטער] איז נאָר געבליבן אין דער געגנט פֿון באַנסקאַ ביסטריצאַ. און דער שטח איז געװעזן אַ קלײנער, און ס’איז זיך שװער געװעזן צום אױפֿנטהאַלט.
David Boder: װאָס איז געװעזן אַ קלײנער?
Baruch Friedman: אַ שטח, אַ... [דײַטש׃] ראַום.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: אַ קלײנער ראַום.
David Boder: װעלכער? דע [דאָס] ... לאַנד איז געװעזן...
Baruch Friedman: דע [דאָס] לאַנד, װעלכע[ס] מיר האָבן זיך געקענט, די... די אױפֿשטענדער [= אױפֿשטענדישע] זאָלן זיך קענען אױפֿהאַלטן. אַזױ דאַס... ס’איז... ס’איז געװעזן װידער אַ פּײַנלעכע [?] זאַך, און... און, און יעדע װאָך, װאָס איז...
David Boder: Ir meynt [es, bay „roym“, dos - ? umklor] shtik [In English] of land.
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] Yo, yo, yo. Dis [this?] maynt ir.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: שטיק לאַנד, יאָ. און איצט, אַז דער דײַטש האָט אַװעקגעצױגן טרופּן פֿון אָסטן, פֿון װײַטן מיזרח, און דערמיט צו אונטערדריקן דעם אױפֿשטאַנד! װײַל דער אױפֿשטאַנד דער גאַנצע האָט געדױערט צירקאַ צװײ מאָנאַטע! און איצט ס’איז... מיר האָבן נאָך נישט געװוּסט, װאָס מיר זאָלן מאַכן. אַלזאָ אַלנפֿאַלס, איך מיט דעם ברודער האָבן זיך געפֿאָרכט [מורא געהאַט] אַרײַנטרעטן אין דער אַרמײ און... און מיר זענען אַרײַן אין זװלאָנען, צו דעם צװאַנציקסטן טרופּ, זענען מיר אױך אײַנגעטרעטן אַהין.
Baruch Friedman: איצט... געקעמפֿט האָבן מיר װי מיר האָבן געקענט נאָר קעמפֿן. דער ברודער איז טאַקע דאָרט געפֿאַלן, אײנער.
David Boder: יאָ?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: װעלכער אײנער? אײַער... ברודער?
Baruch Friedman: דער... מײַן ייִנגערער ברודער...
David Boder: װאָס געװעזן מיט אײַך אין װאַלד.
Baruch Friedman: [אומקלאָר] צוזאַמען. ער איז געפֿאַלן. יאָ. און איך, איך האָב נישט געװוּסט, װאָס איך זאָל מאַכן, אַזױ האָב איך געזען׃ די סלאָװאַקן קעמפֿן נישט פֿאַר זיך אַלײן. זײ װילן, זײ שיקן אַז דאָס ייִדישע בלוט זאָל פֿאַלן, [אומקלאָר], און דער גרױסער אַנטיסעמיטיזם איז געװעזן – אַבי בין איך געװעזן אין דער מײנונג, איך זאָל נישט קעמפֿן. פֿאַר װאָס זאָל איך קעמפֿן, װוּ איך זע, דער אַנטיסעמיטיזם איז נאָך אַזױ װי ער איז געװעזן. אַלזאָ װאָס בין איך געטאָן? איך האָב געזען װאָס אַמאָל איז אַלץ, עה... מער אונטערדריקט, דער אױפֿשטאַנד, פֿאַר... אין משך פֿון צװײ חדשים איז דער... איז דער גאַנצער אױפֿשטאַנד צו גרונדע געגאַנגען. אַזױ דאַס מענטשן, די ייִדן, װעלעכע זײ האָבן זיך קאָנצענטרירט פֿון אַלע עקן דער סלאָװאַקײַ דאָרט אַהין, װעלעכע זײ האָבן געװאָלט זיך דאָרט רעטן, זענען געבליבן הילפֿסלאָז און זײ האָבן נישט געװוּסט װאָס צו טאָן. אַזױ װי יעדער האָט געמאַכט, אַזױ האָב איך אױך געטאָן – אַזױ... געװער האָב איך נאָך געהאַט, זענען מיר געגאַנגען אין װאַלד אַרײַן און אָנגעהױבן אַ... אַ פּאַרטיזאַניש לעבן.
David Boder: װיפֿל מענטשן?
Baruch Friedman: מיר זענען אַרײַנגעגאַנגען... ייִדן זענען אַרײַנגעגאַנגען צירקאַ פֿופֿציק...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: און גױים צירקאַ דרײַסיק.
Baruch Friedman: און מיר האָבן געבילדעט אַ גרופּע פֿון אַכציק מענטשן, אָרגאַניזירט מיט װאַפֿע [= װאָפֿנס].
David Boder: יאָ. און װער איז געװעזן דער קאָמאַנדער?
Baruch Friedman: דער קאָמאַנדער איז געװעזן אַ נישט אַ ייִד, אַ גױישער...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: . . .  אַ געװיסער מײַער/מאיר, ראַפּאָרטשיק מײַער...
Baruch Friedman: ער האָט אונדז קאָמאַנדירט.
David Boder: מע האָט געװוּסט, ער איז געװעזן לאָיאַל, ער איז געװעזן ערלעך?
Baruch Friedman: װי באַלד ער איז געגאַנגען זיך מיט אונדז פֿאַרשטעקן, האָבן מיר געדענקט, אַז מיר קענען אים אָנפֿאַרטרױען [געטרױען, צוטרױ האָבן]. דערפֿאַר׃ װאָלט/העט ער געװען געװעזן אַ פֿאַראַטער – דענק איך – [װעט/װאָלט/העט] ער נישט געװען געגאַנגען זיך פֿאַרשטעקן.
David Boder: און װי האָט זיך [אַרױסגעצײַגט? (= אױסגעװיזן)] װײַטער?
Baruch Friedman: אַז ער איז ריכטיק אױפֿריכטיק געװעזן.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: דען... יאָ. אַלזאָ, אַל־... איך װיל אױך דאָ באַמערקן׃ נאָך דעם זענען געקומען... אָנגעהױבן װידער גרױסע טראַנספּאָרטע. דער דײַטש איז געקומען, האָט באַזעסן די גאַנצ־, עה, באַזעצט די גאַנצע סלאָװאַקײַ, און די טראַנספּאָרטן, װעלעכע זענען... האָבן װידער אָנגעהױבן צו גײן – װײַל פֿון דעם טײל, פֿון די פֿופֿצן טױזנט ייִדן, װעלכע זענען געבליבן, האָט ער נאָך אַרױסגעשלעפּט נאָך צען [טױזנט], און געשיקט װידער אין יאָר, עה, פֿיר און פֿערציק, אין, עה, סעפּטעם־...עה, אָקטאָבער צײַט...
David Boder: נאָך צען טױזנט?
Baruch Friedman: נאָך צען טױזנט האָט ער צוגעשיקט ביז אױף אױשװיץ. צוריק אין... װעלעכע זײַנען... פֿון זײ/די איז איאָ אַ טײל לעבן געבליבן. װײַל דעמלט זענען שױן די קרעמאַטאָריומס אַ ביסל שװאַכער געװעזן.
David Boder: אין װעלכן יאָר איז דאָס געװען?
Baruch Friedman: דאָס איז געװען אין פֿיר און פֿערציקער יאָר.
David Boder: [In German] Am Ende?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] אַם ענדע פֿיר און פֿערציקער יאָר, יאָ.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: נו?
Baruch Friedman: . אַלזאָ און... דאָס איז... מיר זענען אָנגעקומען אַהין – אין דעם װאַלד אַרײַן – אַלזאָ... נאָװעמבער צײַט. איצט האָט אָנגעהױבן אַ שנײ, האָבן מיר זיך... עה, און... עסן איז װײניק געװעזן... האָבן מיר נישט געװוּסט, װאָס... מיר זאָלן /װעלן עפּעס צו טאָן. אַלזאָ האָבן מיר אָנגעהױבן פֿאָרבערײַטונגען צו מאַכן. געמאַכט זיך גריבער, אונטערערדישע בונקערס, מיט װאַך פֿון אַלע פֿיר זײַטן, מיט געװער – און... דאָרט זיך אַנזעסיק געמאַכט, אױסגעזוכט אַ װיכטיקן פּונקט, אַזױ דאַס... דער דײַטש װעט קומען, זאָל מען אים קענען אָנגרײַפֿן, און זיך דאָס לעבן רעטן דורך, װײניקסטנס דורך געװער. איך מײן, דאָס... זאָל מען לײַסטן אַ װידערשטאַנד. אַזױ האָבן מיר געהאַט געלעבט. אײניקע... ס’איז אַ סך מאָל פֿאָרגעקומען׃ עס איז פֿאַרבײַ געגאַנגען אַ דײַטשער פּאַטראָל, אַ פּאַטראָל, װעלעכער ס’האָט אונדז באַמערקט׃ װאָס האָבן מיר געמאַכט? אַזױ, זאָפֿאָרט אַלאַרמירט געװאָרן, און מיר האָבן זײ אַרומגערינגלט און זאָפֿאָרט, עה, אַלע... אױסגעשאָסן. דער דײַטש האָט עװענטועל געװוּסט, אַז דאָרט געפֿינען זיך נאָך פּאַרטיזאַנען, דען ער האָט נאָך גרױס... – חדשים־לאַנג שפּעטער – האָט ער כּסדר, כּסדר נאָכגעזוכט אַלע װעלדער, װאָס איז דאָרט געװעזן. ער האָט אָט־דאָרט זיך נישט [אומקלאָר] געטרױט אַרײַנצוגײן׃ ער האָט געװוּסט, אַז פּאַרטיזאַנען קענען... קענען אים דאָרט אַ סך באַפֿאַלן, און זײ קענען אױך אַ שאָדן מאַכן.
David Boder: [דײַטש] װאָ האַבען זי... [ייִדיש] װי האָבן זײ דען געזוכט, די װעלדער?
Baruch Friedman: זײ האָבן דאָרט געזוכט, די װעלדער, זענען דאָרט געגאַנגען פּאַטראָלן, די דײַטשן...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: . . .  און... אַזױ דאָרט געזוכט.
David Boder: און איר האָט [דאָס?] געזען?
Baruch Friedman: מיר האָבן דאָס אַלײן באַמערקט.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. נאָר אַ סך מאָל, זאָג איך דאָך, איז צו אונדז אױך צוגעקומען אַ פּאַטראָל, האָבן מיר זײ געמוזט אַרומרינגלען און אױסשיסן, זײ אַלע.
David Boder: האָבן זײ נישט פּרוּבירט צו בעטן, מע זאָל זײ נישט שיסן, מע [אומקלאָר]?
Baruch Friedman: מיר האָבן זײ אױפֿגעפֿאָדערט “הענדע האָך!” [הענט אַרױף!]
David Boder: נו?
Baruch Friedman: און זײ האָבן זיך נישט געװאָלט אונטערגעבן.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: נישט געװאָלט אונטערגעבן, זײ האָבן זיך אָנגעהױבן... מיר האָבן [אומקלאָר], װײַל מיר האָבן געקענט דעם טיפּ פֿון דעם דײַטש׃ דער דײַטש האָט אַזױ געװוּסט׃ אַז ער פֿאַלט אַרײַן אין די הענט פֿון אַ פּאַרטיזאַן, איז ער טױט.
David Boder: נו?
Baruch Friedman: אַזױ, דאָס [אַז] זײ האָבן געקעמפֿט אױף לעבן און טױט. זײ האָבן זיך נישט געװאָלט אונטערגעבן, װײַל זײ האָבן געװוּסט, אַז זײ פֿאַלן צו אונדז אַרײַן, זענען זײ... [דײַטש] קאַפּוט.
Baruch Friedman: און... יאָ. אַזױ! געלעבט האָבן מיר...
David Boder: נו, און װען זײ װאָלטן זיך אונטערגעגעבן, װאָס װאָלט איר געטאָן?
Baruch Friedman: װײס איך נישט...
David Boder: װײסט איר ניט. ס’האָט ניט פּאַסירט?
Baruch Friedman: נײן. ס’האָט נישט פּאַסירט.
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: אַ סך פֿאַלן זענען געװעזן׃ מע האָט זײ, עה... דאַס מע האָט, מע האָט געכאַפּט דײַטשע, אַז מע האָט געכאַפּט, זאָגן מיר, אַ גרופּע פֿון צען מענטשן – נישט בײַ אונדזער גרופּע, אין אַנדערע גרופּן –
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: . . .  האָט מען נײַן גע־, אױסגעהרגעט זײ,
Baruch Friedman: אָבער מיט אַ ברוטאַלן טױט, און אײנעם אַװעקגעלאָזט, אַז ער זאָל זען, װי אַזױ ברוטאַל מע האָט זײ געהרגעט, און ער... און ער זאָל קענען דערצײלן, די איבעריקע [אומקלאָר], װי אַזױ מיאוסן טױט זײ זענען געשטאָרבן.
David Boder: װאָס נענט איר “אַ ברוטאַלן טױט”?
Baruch Friedman: נעמען... צום בײַשפּיל האָט גענומען אַ מענטש, מע האָט אים אַרײַנגעהאַקט אַ נאָגל, עה, צװישן די צװײ אױגן, עה... לעבעדיקערהײט.
David Boder: נו?
Baruch Friedman: און... אָדער אַנדערע מיאוסע, ברוטאַלע טױטן.
David Boder: הם.
Baruch Friedman: געקװעלט האָט מען זײ, אַלע. װעגן דעם האָבן זײ זײער מורא געהאַט צו קומען, אַרײַנצופֿאַלן אין פּאַרטיזאַנישע הענט אַרײַן. געגעסן, ס’הײסט, געלעבט האָבן מיר פֿו ןדעם, װעלכע מיר זײַנען יעדן אױף דער נאַכט אָדער, עה... יעדן צװײטן אױף דער נאַכט, אַרומגעגאַנגען אין די דערפֿער אַרײַן, דאָרט אין די אומגעב[נד]איקע דערפֿער, װעלעכע ..., דאָרט אין די דערפֿער אַרײַן, װוּ די דײַטשן האָבן זיך נישט געטרױט [= דערװעגט] אַרײַנצוקומען, װײַל זײ האָבן געװוּסט, אַז דאָרט קענען זײ באַפֿאַלט װערן, דאָרט אי’ [= זײַנען] די פּאַרטיזאַנער.
Baruch Friedman: און די באַפֿעלקערונג האָט אונזד זײער גוט אױפֿגענומען, זײ האָבן אונדז געגעבן צו עסן און צו טרינקען, און פֿלײש, און אָנגעװאַשן זיך, [דײַטש] זאָגאַר [ייִדיש] אַ סך מאָל האָבן מיר זיך געװאַגט [= דערװעגט], אַפֿילו איבערצונעכטיקן אױך דאָרט. און ס’איז נישט... די באַפֿעלקערונג איז נישט אַזױ װײַט שלעכט געװעזן, װײַל זײ האָבן געװוּסט, אַז ס’איז אױך אין זײער אינטערעס, װײַל ס’איז אױך געװעזן אַ סך גױים דערונטער. נישט נאָר בלױז ייִדן. אַזױ האָבן מיר געלעבט אַ היפּש לאַנגע צײַט.
Baruch Friedman: ביז ס’איז געשען אַמאָל אַ פֿאַל – עה, די רוסן האָבן זיך גענענטערט, די פֿראָנט איז זײער נאָענט געװעזן, און דאָס איז שױן געװעזן אין פֿינף און פֿערציקסטן יאָר.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: עה, און, עה... יענע צײַט... און מיר האָבן געװאַרט, אַז די רוסן װעלן אונדז שױן קומען באַפֿרײַען. פֿאַר[אומקלאָר]. איצט איז אָבער געװעזן׃ די רוסן האָבן זיך אַנידערגעשטעלט אין... ברעזנאָ נאַד הראָנאָם, דאָס איז צװאַנציק קילאָמעטער פֿאַר אונדז, און זענען נישט װײַטער געגאַנגען. מיר האָבן נישט געװוּסט, װאָס צו מאַכן. דער פֿראָנט איז דאָרט געװעזן זײער אַ שװערער, און די דײַטשע פּאַטראָלן זענען כּסדר [אַרױס און אַרום?] געגאַנגען, זײ האָבן שױן געשפּירט, אַז, עה... דאָרט זענען פּאַרטיזאַנען – זײ האָבן דאָך געװוּסט – האָבן זײ אײניקע מאָל געשאָסן אױך מינען אױף אונדז, און... און זײ האָבן נישט געװוּסט, עה׃ מיר האָבן [= זענען] געשטאַנען אין זײער אַ שװערן מצבֿ.
David Boder: [In German] Also wieviel Partisanen [In Yiddish] zaynen yetst gevezn?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] צירקאַ אַכציק׃
David Boder: אַכציק.
Baruch Friedman: פֿופֿציק ייִדן, ...
David Boder: האָט איר זיך פֿאַרבונדן מיט די רוסן?
Baruch Friedman: עה, שפּעטער.
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: זענען מיר דאַן געגאַנגען, איז, דאָך, איז געװעזן אַ פֿאַל, װוּ די... אַ דײַטשער פּאַטראָל, אַ שטאַרקער פּאַטראָל, װאָס איז נאָענט צום פֿראָנט געװעזן, איז פֿאַרבײַגעגאַנגען און... זײ האָבן אונדז באַמערקט. און איצט איז געװעזן אַזױ אַ פֿאַל, דאַס מיר האָבן זײ נישט געהאַט אַרומגערינגלט, נאָר װאָס דען? מיר האָבן געשאָסן – און זײ, און אַ גרעסערער טײל איז אַנטלאָפֿן.
David Boder: [In German] Also. Wollen Sie mir beschreiben, zey zaynen gevezn akhtsik mentshn: vos far, eh [In English] armament, [In Yiddish] vos far, eh, vafn hobn [In German] Sie [In Yiddish] gehat?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] יאָ. װאָפֿן איז געװעזן׃ מײַסטנס אױטאָמאַטן,
David Boder: אױטאָמאַטישע פּיסטאָלן?
Baruch Friedman: אױטאָמאַטישע פּיסטאָלן, די... די... רוסישע...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: רוסישע...
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Die hat man von di Russen bekumen?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] יאָ, בײַם אױפֿשטאַנד, װאָס די רוסן האָבן אונטערשטיצט דעם אױפֿשטאַנד...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: דאַמאַלס, און עה... גראַנאַ־, האַנט־גראַנאַטן...און ס’איז אױך געװעזן צירקאַ זעקס מאַשין־געװערע, לײַכטע מאַשין־געװערע, און אײן שטאַרק, עה... שטאַרקע מאַשין־געװערע, װעלכע מע האָט נישט געקענט אַזױ װײַט באַניצן, װײַל ס’איז שװערער געװעזן איבערצוטראָגן.
Baruch Friedman: מײַסטנס, אַז מע באַניצט נאָר מיט לײַכטע מאַשין־געװערע.
David Boder: יאָ. און/פֿון װוּ [=װאַנען] האָט מען געהאַט די אַמוניציע?
Baruch Friedman: מוניציאָן האָבן מיר געהאַט נאָך פֿון אױפֿשטאַנד. אַלעס. פֿון אױפֿשטאַנד.
David Boder: אַלזאָ, װאָס װאַר דאַמאַלס: װאָלן מיר צוריקקומען נאָך אױפֿן אױפֿשטאַנד׃ װער זענט... װער האָבן אָנגעפֿאַנגען דעם אױפֿשטאַנד? די, עה... רוסן זענען אַרײַנגעקומען?
Baruch Friedman: נײן, דאָס איז געװעזן רוסישע פּאַרטיזאַנער אָבער... זײ האָבן אונטערשטיצט; אָרגאַניזירט איז עס געװעזן אָפֿיץצעל דורך אַ סלאָװאַקישן אױפֿשטאַנד.
David Boder: יאָ? אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: אָבער ס’איז נישט געלונגען.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: װײַל ס’איז געװעזן אַ גרױסער פֿאַראַט. און שפּעטער האָט מען אונטערדריקט. דער דײַטש איז געקומען, האָט אונטערדריקט דעם אױפֿשטאַנד.
David Boder: אָבער װערענד דעם אױפֿשטאַנד זײַט איר פּאַרטיזאַ־... זײַט איר פֿרײַ געקומען פֿון לאַגער און איר האָט מיטגענומען װאָפֿן?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ, פֿרײַ פֿון לאַגער. מיטגענומען װאָפֿנ[ס]. מיר האָבן אונדז אָנגעשלאָסן אַן דען אױפֿשטאַנד, יאָ.
David Boder: נו, װײַטער.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. אַלז... עה, איז דער... װיל איך... איך װיל איצט שױן קומען צו דעם, װי מיר זענען אַריבער צו די רוסן.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: אַלזאָ, איז דאָס געװעזן... דעמאָלס, װען דער פּאַטראָל איז געקומען, דער דײַטשער פּאַטראָל, און מיר האָבן זײ נישט געקענט אַלע אַרומנעמען, און אַ גרױסער טײל פֿון די [= זײ] איז אַנטלאָפֿן צוריק. און זײ האָבן דאָרט געזאָגט, אַז דאָ איז אַ גרױסע מחנה פֿון פּאַרטיזאַנען, און מע מוז זײ זען [דײַטש] אַבצורױמען. [ייִדיש] האָבן זײ אָנגעהױבן מיט [אומקלאָר] צו... װײַל זײ האָבן זיך נישט געטרױט צוצוקומען נעהער [נעענטער], זײ האָבן נישט געװוּסט, װאָסערע גרױסע קראַפֿט דאָרט איז, האָבן זײ אָנגעהױבן מיטן, עה, מיט מינעס צו שיסן אױף אונדז, און אונדז צו פֿאַרטרײַבן. זאָפֿאָרט איז אונדזער קאָמענדאַנט, האָט געהאַט אַ באַראַטונג, [אומקלאָר] מיט דער הױפּטזײַט, און, עה, דאָס איז געװעזן עלף פֿאַר מיטאָג, און [אום?] פֿיר נאָך מיטאָג האָבן מיר זיך שױן גענומען אַנטשלאָסנאַריבערצוגײן די גרענעץ. ער האָט אױסגעאַרבעט אַ פּלאַן... ער האָט אױסגעאַרבעט אַ פּלאַן און, און... בײַ פֿיר נאָך מיטאָג האָבן מיר זיך גענומען, אַרומגערינגלט דעם גאַנצן פֿראָנט – דאָרט זענען אױך געװעזן רומענער, װאָס האָבן געקעמפֿט קעגן..., קעגן דעם... דײַטש – און מיר זײַנען אױסגע־, מיר האָבן זײ אױסגע[-זוכט?/-הרגעט?] און, און... אַזױ בײַלײַפֿיק אום צװײ בײַ נאַכט זענען מיר אַריבער דעם פֿראָנט־ליניע – אױך מיט די קאַבלס, מיט אַלעם – מיר זענען אַלזאָ געװען פֿאָרבערײַטעט
David Boder: [Vos meynt „kabl”? / (...?) mit kabl?]
Baruch Friedman: . . .  די טעלעפֿאָן־דראָנט פֿון אײן פֿראָנט אין צװײטן פֿראָנט, פֿון... די, די קאַבל [קאָבלען/דראָטן] זענען געצױגן געװעזן
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: . . .  און אום פֿיר אין דער פֿרי זענען מיר אַריבער, עה, צו די רוסן.
David Boder: האָבן די רוסן געװוּסט, אַז איר װעט... אַז איר קומט?
Baruch Friedman: זײ האָבן זיך געפֿרעגט, װער דאָס זענען, האָבן מיר געזאָגט׃ [רוסיש] “װאַשי” – “אונדזערע”.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: זאָפֿאָרט האָבן זײ אונדז אױפֿגענומען און מיר זענען פֿרײַ געקומען.
David Boder: נו.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. צו דעם װיל איך נאָך... מיר זען־/האָבן געהאַט פֿאָרבערײַטעט צו אַ קאַמף געװעזן
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: . . .  פֿאַר דאָס קומט, איז, עה... זעלבסטפֿאַרשטענדלעך העט מען געװעזן אַ װידערשטאַנד געלײַסטעט.
David Boder: For... [In German] Gegen wen?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] קעגן דעם דײַטש, װעלעכער...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: . . .  אין דעם, בײַם אַריבערגאַנג.
Baruch Friedman: און... ס’איז געװעזן פֿאַרבונדן מיט גרױזסע שװעריקײַטן – דער שנײ איז געװעזן גרױס, צירקאַ צװײ מעטער, און סע די גרױסע געבירג אַרױף־ און אַרומצוגײן – אָבער טראָץ דעם האָבן מיר נישט געקוקט, מיר זענען... ס’איז אױך געװעזן אַ סך גרױען דערונטער, װעלכע ס’האָבן שװער אױסגעהאַלטן, אָבער מיר זענען בשלום אַריבער געקומען.
David Boder: אָה, איר האָט געהאַט גרױען צװישן די פּאַרטיזאַנען?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. אױך פֿרױען.
David Boder: װיפֿל פֿרױען זײַנען געװעזן?
Baruch Friedman: ס’איז געװעזן צירקאַ... אַכצן פֿרױען אױך. אייִדישע פֿרױען.
David Boder: האָבן די פֿרױען געשאָסן, גע־...?
Baruch Friedman: אָה, אַלעס אַזױ טײלגענומען אַזױ װי מענער. קײן אונטערשיד געװעזן. אַזױ װי מענער, אַזױ אױך פֿרױען.
David Boder: נו.
Baruch Friedman: און אַזױ זענען מיר דאַן אַריבער – דאָס איז געװעזן דעם צװעלפֿנט פֿעברואַר פֿינף און פֿערציק זענען מיר אַריבער...
David Boder: צו די רוסן.
Baruch Friedman: . . .  צו די רוסן.
David Boder: נו, װאָס האָט דאַן פּאַסירט?
Baruch Friedman: יעדער אײנער איז פֿרײַ געװאָרן...
David Boder: װאָס הײסט, האָט מען אײַך געבראַכט [ענגליש] ביפֿאָר [ייִדיש] אַן אָפֿיציר? האָט מען אײַך געבראַכט [אומקלאָר]?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ, זענען מיר אַהינגעקו־... מיר האָבן... זענען מיר אַהינגעקומען צו דעם הױפּטקאָמאַנדאַנט, דעם הױפּטקװאַרטיר, און מע האָט אונדז אױסגעהאָרכט׃ װוּ מיר זענען געװעזן, מע האָט אַ, עה, שטיקל... דער אָפֿיציר האָט [אומקלאָר] געגעבן אַ איבערבליק, אַ פֿראָנט־איבערבליק, װוּ זײ, װי אַזױ די דײַטשן שטײען דאָרט און יעדער אײנער האָט באַקומען אַ באַשטעטיקונג פֿון די רוסן, אַז ער קען פֿרײַ זיך אַהײמגײן, און יעדער אײנער איז (אױך/זיך אױף) אַהײם געגאַנגען. פֿרײַװיליקע [האָבן די רוסן...?]...
David Boder: אָבער די רוסן שױן געהאַט אײַער שטאָט..., אײַער עה, װוּ, אַ הײם...?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. מײַן הײם האָבן זײ שױן געהאַט, יאָ.
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: שױן געהאַט, יאָ.
David Boder: נו?
Baruch Friedman: און אַזױ, דאַס יעדער אײנער האָט זיך שױן געקענט אַהײמגײן פֿרײַ. פֿרײַװיליקע, װעלכע זײ האָבן געװאָלט, זענען דאָרט, עה...
David Boder: געבליבן מיט די רוסן?
Baruch Friedman: פּערל; געבליבן מיט די רוסן, זײ האָבן זיך פֿרײַװיליק... אָדער געמאָלדן אין דער טשעכאָסלאָװאַקישער אַרמײ.
David Boder: Da war schon de tshekhoslovakishe...?
Baruch Friedman: [װײַל?] דעמאָלט האָט [עס דאָך?]..., ס’איז געקומען פֿון רוסלאַנד און מע האָט זיך געמוזט מעלדן אין קאָשיצע.
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: נו, זאָגט מיר דאָס׃ אין אײַער טשעכאָ־... אין אײַער פּאַרטיזאַנען, עה... גרופּע, פּאַרטיזאַנערגרופּע׃ װיפֿל זײַנען געװעזן אָפֿיצירן, װיפֿל זײַנען... װי האָט מען דאָס געפֿירט, דעם גאַנצן... עה...
Baruch Friedman: ס’איז געװעזן אַ... דרײַ אָפֿיצירע זענען געװעזן.
David Boder: [In English] Yes. [In Yiddish] Ayer, der shef [chef], Mayer ...?
Baruch Friedman: מײַער... דאַן איז געװעזן, עה, ביטשאַנאָװסקי – אײנער, אַ... אױך אַ סלאָװאַק -
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: דאַן איז געװעזן נאָך אײנער, עה... קען איך מיך נישט גענױער דערמאָנען, װי אַזױ ער האָט געהײסן.
David Boder: אַ ייִד [ענגליש] אָר [ייִדיש] נישט אַ ייִד?
Baruch Friedman: נײן, נישט קײן ייִד.
David Boder: אַלזאָ די דרײַ אָפֿיצירן זײַנען געװעזן...
Baruch Friedman: . . .  זײַנען געװעזן גױים...
David Boder: . . .  גױים. און...?
Baruch Friedman: פֿאַר װאָס? װײַל זײ האָבן געהאַט די טעכניק, די אױסאיבונג, די ריכטיקע. אונדזערע... צװישן זיך האָבן מיר אױך געהאַט אַן אָנפֿירער, אײנעם – דער האָט...
David Boder: אַ ייִדישן?
Baruch Friedman: . . .  געהײסן גרינװאַלד.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: אַ ייִדישן אָנפֿירער, גרונװאַלס. מיר האָבן געהאַט אַ ראַדיאָ־אַפּאַראַט...
David Boder: יאָ. צו שיקן [ענגליש] אָר [ייִדיש] צו... [דײַטש] עמפּפֿאַנגען?
Baruch Friedman: נײן, צו עמפֿאַנגען – נאָר אַזױ האָבן מיר געװוּסט אַלע נײַעס...
David Boder: יאָ?
Baruch Friedman: . . .  און, עה... מיר האָבן אױך געהאַט אַ... אַ, װי אַזױ הײסט דאָס נאָר... אַן אַפּאַראַט, װעלכע צום אױשאָרכן... – אַ [נאַטשוּװאַצי??]-אַפּאַראַט׃ ציהערן די טעלעפֿאָן־געשפּרעכע.
David Boder: אַהאַ!
Baruch Friedman: דאָס האָבן מיר געהאָט.
David Boder: װי, עה... װי האָט דאָס געאַרבעט?
Baruch Friedman: דאָס, מיר האָבן צוגעהערט אַלץ די... די... די פֿראָנט־פֿאַרבינדונגען צװישן דײַטש, און דאַן דער הױפּט־, עה, דער הױפּטקאָמאַנדאַנט האָט דאָס איבערגעגעבן צו דער העכערער שטעלע פֿון די פּאַרטיזאַנען, װײַל דאָרט, העכער, נישט װײַט, איז געװעזן אַ הױפּט־צענטראַלע, אַ, עה פּונקט פֿון אַ גרעסערער פּאַרטיזאַנער[אומקלאָר].
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Oh! Es war gewesen noch andere partizaner?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] נאָך אַנדערע. נישט נאָר מיר בלױז. מיר זענען נאָר געװעזן אַ קלײנע אָפּטײלונג פֿון די... אָפּצװײַגן.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: אָבער דאָרט זײַנען געװעזן הונדערטער און הונדערטער פּאַרטיזאַנען אין דער גאַנצער געגנט.
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: נו?
Baruch Friedman: עס איז געקומען אַ סך מאָל אַ אױפֿגאַבע׃ אײנע, אַ בריק צו שפּרענגען אָדער, עה... אָדער אײנע ‘ן צוג צו שפּרענגען...
David Boder: הם.
Baruch Friedman: אַלזאָ דאָס אַלעס געװעזן אין דעם פֿאָרעם [= אין דער פֿאָרעם], װאָס... עס איז געװען אַ שליחות פֿון אײנעם, אײן, אײן אױפֿגאַבע׃ [דער און דער װאָס קען(?)/דער און דער מוז גײן(?)] – איז מען געגאַנגען.
David Boder: נו. װיפֿל פֿון די פּאַרטיזאַנען זענען געפֿאַלן?
Baruch Friedman: צירקאַ פֿיר.
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: די גאַנצע צײַט פֿיר מענטשן געפֿאַלן, נישט מער.
David Boder: Vifil yidn ven, eh... [In German] waren darunter?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] עה, ייִדן איז, עה, איז נישט גע־... אײנע איז געװען פֿאַרװוּנדעט, אײנער איז געשטאָרבן – נאָרמאַל געשטאָרבן -
David Boder: יאָ?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: נו, װײַטער?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ. נו, װאָס נאָך? [אומקלאָר]
David Boder: [In German] Und dann sind Sie [In Yiddish] gekumen aheym?
Baruch Friedman: פּערל: אַהײם. אָבער דאָס איז... יאָ, איצט װײַטער נאָך װאָס איז געװעזן? – איך קום אַהײם, האָב איך גאָר נישט געטראָפֿן. אײנער אַלײן פֿון דער פֿאַמיליע...
David Boder: קײנער?
Baruch Friedman: קײנער נישט.
David Boder: נו...
Baruch Friedman: פּערל: פֿון דער גאַנצער פֿאַמיליע אַלײן. װאָס מאַכט מען דאָ?
David Boder: און װער איז געװעזן אין שטוב, װוּ איר האָט געװױנט?
Baruch Friedman: קײ־... אַלעס איז געװעזן, עה, װיסט׃ צעבראָכן די פֿענצטער, צעבראָכן [דאָס הױז (?) / דאָס האָלץ (?)], אַלעס, אַלעס...
David Boder: װאָס הײסט׃ מען האָט אײַך באָמבאַרדירט?
Baruch Friedman: [אומקלאָר] נישט [אומקלאָר]. דאָס איז געװעזן, װײַל דאָס הױז איז [דײַטש] לער [= לײדיק] [ייִדיש] געשטאַנען, נישט אײַנבאַװױנט.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: זענען אַהינגעגאַנגען מענטשן און זײ האָבן דאָרט אַלעס איבערגעװאָרפֿן, אַלעס אַרױסגעבראָכן – אַזױ דאַס דאָס גאַנצע הױז איז גאַנץ, טאָטאַל לער געבליבן. גאָר נישט איז געװעזן.
David Boder: װעמענס הױז איז געװעזן׃ אײַער אײגענעס?
Baruch Friedman: אונדזער אײגן הױז.
David Boder: נו...
Baruch Friedman: און אױך פֿעלדער האָבן מיר געהאַט דערין דאָרט. און...
David Boder: [In German] Pferde?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] פֿעלדער, פֿעלדער.
David Boder: יאָ. נו?
Baruch Friedman: די פֿעלדער האָבן די גױים באַאַרבעט די/אַ גאַנצע צײַט... האָט מען געװאָלט עפּעס... אַ... – מע קומט אַהײם, האָב איך געמײנט, דאָס... מע װעט האָבן אַ ביסל מערער [אומקלאָר]! מע קומט אַהײם, מע איז שױן באַפֿרײַט, מע װעט האָבן אַ ביסעלע מערער. דערװײַל, זע איך, איז פֿאָר נישט. האָב איך פּרובירט, דאָרט צו... אײניקע, װעלכע איך האָב געװוּסט, אַז זײ האָבן אָנגעפֿירט מיט די טראַנספּאָרטן קעגן ייִדן׃ האָב איך געװאָלט זיך קען זײ נוקם זײַן... [איך מײן (?)] איך האָב געדענקט, איך האָב אַ שטיקל רעכט... אַ שטיקל פּאַרטיזאַן געװעזן...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: האָט מען מיך אױסגעלאַכט! פֿאַר װאָס? װײַל בײַ די אָנפֿירערס פֿון דער סלאָװאַקישער רעגירונג זענען געװעזן דיזעלבע אַנטיסעמיטן, װעלעכע זענען געװעזן פֿריער, פֿאַר דעם. אַזױ דאַס... איך האָב מיך נישט געטרױט, איך האָב מיך [אומקלאָר] צו דעם׃ איך לאָז אַלעס שטײן, איך לאָז דאָס הױז שטײן, איך לאָז די פֿעלדער שטײן, און איך גײ מיר ץצ מײַן ציל׃ איך גײ מיר אַהײם. אַלזאָ האָב איך מיך גענומען, איך גײ, עה... װיל איך אַריבער... ערשט שפּעטער, די גאַן־... נאָך דעם װי איך בין אַ גאַנצע צײַט [אומקלאָר].
David Boder: נישט פֿאַרקױפֿט דעם הױז?
Baruch Friedman: נײן, מע קען נישט פֿאַרקױפֿן, װאָרין/װײַל זײ האָבן נישט צוריקגעגעבן, די סלאָװאַקן האָבן נאָך ביז הײַנט נישט ץצריקגעגעבן די ייִדן די פֿאַרמעגנס. און אַלעס איז נאָך אַזױ װי עס איז געװעזן.
David Boder: הם.
Baruch Friedman: האָב איך מיך אַנטשלאָסן׃ װאָס זאָל איך װאַרטן? עס קען קומען נאָך עפּעס שלעכטס אָדער... און מע האָט נאָך געהערט אַ סך מאָל די פּאָגראָמען אױף ייִדן – דאָ האָט מען געשלאָגן, און דאָרט האָט מען געשלאָגן... אַז מען האָט נאָך געװאָלט עפּעס... אַ גרעכט[י]קײַט געפֿינען, האָט מען נאָך באַצאָלט מיטן לעבן אַ סך מאָל מענטשן אױך. בין איך געגאַנגען אַריבער אױף דײַטשלאַנד און פֿון דאָרטן װײַטער צום ציל פֿון ארץ.
David Boder: און נו, דערצײלט מיר׃ װי זײַט איר געגאַנגען דורך דײַטשלאַנד און װי זײַט איר געקומען נאָך איטאַליע?
Baruch Friedman: דאָס איז... דורך אַ טראַנספּאָרט בין איך אַריבער, עה... איך בין געקומען פֿון פּראַג, האָב איך באַקומען אַ געװיסע אָנװײַזונג׃ דעמאָלט און דעמאָלט גײט אַ טראַנספּאָרט, און דעמאָלס און דעמאָלס...
David Boder: אַ טראַנספּאָרט פֿון װאָס?
Baruch Friedman: פֿון ייִדן, װעלכער עס גײט אַריבער אױף דײַטשלאַנד, און מיט דעם טראַנספּאָרט, דאָרט און דאָרט זאָל איך מיך שטעלן, אױף דעם פּונקט... און דאָרט װעל איך אַריבערגײן. ס’איז אױך אַזױ געװעזן, גענױ אין דער ריכטיקער צײַט, אין דערזעלבן...
David Boder: [In German (Yiddish word order)] Wer hat euch gegeben die Benachrichtigung, die, eh... die Tschechen [In English] or...?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] נײן, אַלעס ייִדן. נאָר ייִדן.
David Boder: דער טראַנספּאָרט איז געװעזן אַן אײַזנבאַן־צוג?
Baruch Friedman: נײן, צו פֿוס.
David Boder: אָה! איז געװעזן אַ גרופּע... נישט, מע האָט געקענט [אומקלאָר] פֿאָרן...
Baruch Friedman: נײן, נײן... נײן, נײן, נײן... ביז צו דער גרענעץ...
David Boder: [אומקלאָר]
Baruch Friedman: ביז צו דער גרענעץ... מיט דעם... צוג, מיטן צוג.
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: . . . מיטן צוג...
David Boder: נו?
Baruch Friedman: און איבער דער גרענעץ אַריבער, דאָרט אױף דעם איז געװעזן אַ זאַמלפּונקט, און דאָרט זענען מיר אַריבער דער גרענעץ געגאַנגען צו פֿוס, זענען מיר געגאַנגען צירקאַ צװעלעף קילאָמעטער...
David Boder: לעגאַל אָדער אילעגאַל?
Baruch Friedman: אילעגאַל.
David Boder: Nu, un, eh, vi hot ir gehat gelt tsu forn un [In German] dies un das? [In Yiddish] Hobn di rusn aykh vos gegebn, a vu hot ir... [? umklor].
Baruch Friedman: נײן, דאָס נישט. אַזױ, ס’איז נאָך... ס’איז געװעזן אַזױ, דאַס די... די אונרר”אַ האָט געשטיצט [לײַט (?)/ װײַט (?)], און מע האָט באַקומען אױשילף פֿון דזשױנט, אַזױ דאַס... אַזױ װײַט איז נאָך געװעזן, דאַס... מע האָט געקענט אַריבערקומען.
David Boder: נו? אַלזאָ?
Baruch Friedman: און... פֿון דאָרט בין איך, אין דײַטשלאַנד בין איך אָנגעזעסן אַ צײַט פֿון דרײַ חדשים, פֿיר חדשין...
David Boder: װאָסערע זאַכן האָט איר מיט זיך געהאַט?
Baruch Friedman: אײן רוקזאַק מיט זאַכן, װאָס איך האָב באַקומען, װאָס עפּעס האָב איך מיך גע[-הײַט (? = געהאַט?)] מיט זיך, און עפּעס, עה... װאָס איך האָב באַקומען פֿון דער אונרר”אַ, פֿון דזשױנט, עה...
David Boder: װאָס האָט איר באַקומען?
Baruch Friedman: אַ הױז[ן] מיט אַ רעקל...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: און... מיט אַ העמד, און אַריבער דער גרענעץ. װאָס ברױכט [= דאַרף] מען – הײַנט ברױכט מען דאָך נישט מער.
David Boder: נו. װאָס הײסט, מען ברױכט נישט מער?
Baruch Friedman: מען ברױכט נישט מער – װאָס מע האָט אָן... הײַנט ברױכט מען נישט מער. װאָס װײניקער מע האָט, איז בעסער...
David Boder: נו...
Baruch Friedman: עס איז גרינגער צו גײן.
David Boder: װײַטער.
Baruch Friedman: און... דאָרט בין איך אָנגעזעסן אין דײַטשלאַנד צירקאַ דרײַ און אַ האַלב מאָנאַט און... – אָדער ביז פֿיר – און װײַטער מיט אַ [טראַנספּאָרט (?)]...
David Boder: װוּ זײַט איר געזעסן אין דײַטשלאַנד?
Baruch Friedman: פּער׃ אין פֿירט.
David Boder: אַלזאָ נענט דאָס נישט אַ טראַנספּאָרט׃ דאָס זײַנען געװעזן גרופּן, װאָס האָבן באַשלאָסן צו גײן. דאָס װאַר ניט אָפֿיציעל, זאָצוזאַגן [אַזױ צו זאָגן], דאַס די... אונרר”אַ האָט געגעבן אַ טראַנספּאָרט...
Baruch Friedman: נײן. אונרר”אַ האָט נישט געגעבן, נאָר דאָס זענען געװעזן ייִדן, װעלכע זײ האָבן אָרגאַניזירט ספּעציעל טראַנספּאָרטע, װעלכע זענען געגאַנגען טאָג־טעגלעך.
David Boder: יאָ. און װוּ איז מען געגאַנגען?
Baruch Friedman: אױף... יעדער איז געגאַנגען אין אַ דײַטשן לאַגער אַרײַן.
David Boder: יאָ. אין אַ דײַטשן לאַגער אַרײַן.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: אין װעלכן זײַט... – אין די אַמעריקאַנישע צאָנע, אין די ענגלישע צאָנע, װוּ...?
Baruch Friedman: אײניקע... מע איז אַריבערגעקומען אױף דער דײַטשער זײַט, האָט זיך יעדער אײנער געקענט גײן װי ער האָט געװאָלט.
David Boder: יאָ. נו?
Baruch Friedman: איך בין געגאַנגען אױף לאַגער פֿירט, דאָרט האָב איך געהאַט אַ... באַקאַנטן, און דאָרט בין איך אַהין...
David Boder: איר האָט געװוּסט, דאַס איר האָט דאָרט אַ באַקאַנטן?
Baruch Friedman: עה, שפּ־... איך בי ןגעװעזן... אין, עה אין... ערשט אַ באַזוך אין פֿירט...
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Baruch Friedman: האָב איך דאָרט געטראָפֿן, איך האָב געדענקט, דאַס איך װעל דאָרט טרעפֿן מײַנעם באַקאַנטן, בלײַב איך דאָרט. װען נישט, גײ איך אין אַ צװײטן לאַגער.
David Boder: נו, װי גײט מען עס רום דאָרטן אין דײַטשלאַנד? האָט מען אײַך...
Baruch Friedman: מען פֿאָרט אַרום.
David Boder: . . .  נישט אָפּגעשטעלט?
Baruch Friedman: נײן. קײנעם האָט מען נישט אָפּגעשטעלט. אַלעס איז פֿרײַ געװעזן, מע האָט... קײנעם קײן מאָל נישט לעגיטימירט. אָן, אָן פּאַפּירן.
David Boder: יאָ. נו, װײַטער?
Baruch Friedman: און איך בין אַהין געקומען און דאָרטן מיך רעגיסטרירט, בין איך דאָרט געװעזן צירקאַ דרײַ און אַ האַלב מאָנאַט.
David Boder: [In German] In Wirt?
Baruch Friedman: In Fürth.
David Boder: Fürth. F.
Baruch Friedman: F-Ü-R-T.
David Boder: Ja, gut.
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] דאָס איז בײַ נירנבערג.
David Boder: אַלזאָ? נו, װײַטער?
Baruch Friedman: און פֿון דאָרט בין איך װײַטער אַריבערגעקומען, עה... יאָ... אַזױ װי אַ אַלטער ציאָניסט, האָב איך מיך... בין איך געװעזן אין אַ קיבוץ, אין [אומקלאָר].
David Boder: פֿירט האָט געהאַט אַ קיבוץ?
Baruch Friedman: קיבוצים, מערערע קיבוצים...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ, ציאָניסטישע קיבוצים. און, עה... זײ זענען... מיר זענען דאַן צוגעקומען צו [אומקלאָר] פֿאַרטײלונג, װער עס ברױך צו קומען קײן ארץ, בין איך אױך געװעזן אײנער, און איך בין אַריבער, עה, מיט איבעריקע, אױך מיט אַ טראַנספּאָרט, אַהער אױף איטאַליע.
David Boder: אַהאַ. און איר זײַט געקומען דירעקט נאָך װוּ? נאָך רױם [ענגליש] אָר...?
Baruch Friedman: מיר זענען געקומען נאָך מילאַנאָ.
David Boder: נאָך מילאַנאָ?
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: Und zayt arayngegangen [In German] zu wem? Zum Joint, [In English] or [what?]...?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] דאָ זענען מיר אַרײַנגעגאַנגען, עה, נאָך [אומקלאָר]. אַ ייִד גײט פֿאַרשידן...
David Boder: יאָ.
Baruch Friedman: יאָ.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Und jetzt, von hier vart ir tsu geyn...?
Baruch Friedman: [In Yiddish] װײַטער קײן ארץ.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 108, Abram Perl, which we started at Spool 107, the last ten minutes. It is a story of a young man who was not in a German concentration camp but spent the time in Czechslovakia fighting for the...the liberation of Czechoslovakia or the cause of the Allies and mostly fighting...and also fighting for his life. September 2nd, 1946. Tradate, a community place for displaced Jews, specially young people, who live in Kibbutzim, what they call. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] איז נאָך עטװאָס, װאָס איר װילט מיר זאָגן?
Baruch Friedman: [In English] No, no.
David Boder: [In German] Danke.
Baruch Friedman: Bitte.